FBI agent spoke to Steven paddocks
girlfriend for hours looking for clues
in a public statement yesterday Marilu
denly called paddock a kind caring quiet
man
and she said she was never aware of any
sign that he was planning this Massacre
Depa gaze is in Washington with new
details from Dan Lee's story
Jeff good morning good morning Dan Lee's
description of the killer contradicts
what investigators are seeing so far
someone who was meticulously planning
building an arsenal and then putting his
deadly plan into action still in her for
our interview with investigators Dan Lee
denied that she knew what he was up to I
loved him and hoped for a quiet future
together with him after arriving in the
US and speaking through her attorney Dan
Lee says it was patek who wanted her to
go to the Philippines I was worried at
first the unexpected trip home and then
the money was a way of breaking up with
me it never occurred to me in any way
whatsoever he was planning violence
authorities believe Patek may not have
been planning alone based on the amount
of weapons and ammunition found at the
crime scene and in searches of his
properties you gotta make the assumption
there he had to have some help at some
point investigators are looking for
anyone who can provide the answers
there's people that could help us
understand this individual she is the
key palmer FBI profiler Mary Ellen
O'Toole says even the smallest details
could help investigators learn more
about panic what kinds of things did he
find that irritated him what were his
personal habits
what were his spending habits another
important aspect of the investigation to
determine whether his mental health
played a role in specifically whether he
fit the clinical description of a
psychopath someone who has no guilt for
what they do somebody who who can be
very controlling and dominating and I'd
walk her through these personality
traits to see if those sound at all
familiar to the man that she knew in
1969 paddocks father was on the FBI's
most wanted list for bank robbery and at
the time he
is called a psychopath danly who is not
under arrest remains a key figure in the
case and investigators want to question
her again
Norah alright Jeff thanks so much your
reporting